minutes of the previous minute meeting
that's ages
three to seven in the pack
i've got one issues raised chair yeah
um there was a
request from the capsule brush food for
an update on the taxi the rank i have
had an update from the public health and
housing manager who has stated initial
discussions with the property team
highlighted potential issues with
maintaining demarcation of the area
surface markings in the working key area
potentially making an unsustainable
option however wider options are now
pursued at this were not consumed at
this time north since due to conflicting
pressures
and apologies afforded to the committee
for that we'll rectify this matter and
take it up with a new estate manager to
determine options and costs for
facilitating the direction of the
committee
um
committee so it has been put on hold for
various reasons that that will now be
pursued
so that'll be on the agenda for that so
we'll put on the agenda for next time
yes
let's do it that's pretty swiss response
but it's only taken about two years
[Laughter]
no
um grant funding in relation to clean
air schemes
um
licensed officer will do research
see if there's anything similar
available is that something this is not
at the moment so they only provide grant
funding to those authorities that are
actually implementing clean air schemes
so there's nothing available at the
moment obviously things are changing
as
we sort of go along whether there will
be any further issues
we
such as london for instance just
extended those i believe they have yeah
yeah yes because i have to double check
without going up so there's one and i
think next year
and that related something else to that
i'm not sure what the criteria is to be
able to apply for a keynesian i'm not
sure we didn't we didn't qualify for
that
further down sorry about um
euro six emissions um
just
agreed to remove this from the items for
consultation
yes
yes
no we took that off the console we have
done the euro 6 to 2026 but initially we
put
um 2022
but we removed the 2022 and pushed it up
to 2026 which is what we did in the
revised consultation
and the reason for that was obviously
the taxi drivers couldn't afford to buy
new you know vehicles
you know within a year
okay
well i'll move those minutes as a sure
inaccurate record from the chair if
anybody would like to settle it
against the bush be second
right
well there's a favor
abstaining
against oh i'm in spain so you're
ultimately here
okay declaration declarations of
[Music]
five urgent matters information we've
brought forward with the permission of
the chair and the committee do we have
anything
nothing urgent okay
six right uh review of the taxi policy
okay yeah following on from the minutes
of the previous meeting where we did the
informal consultation with now and
taking the formal consultation
which ended
up in 8th of october
i've
provided details of the responses which
are fairly low responses but then it's
not we don't generally get much response
to
taxi surveys from anybody other than the
taxi trade
but we have done a wide consultation
limited responses um so those responses
have been considered um
i think probably the best way to do is
if we will go to appendix c if i run
through
um
each
each subject as we go through and if
anybody wants to raise any queries as we
go through we can do it
i've also met with the taxi liaison
committee last week
and discussed these proposals and
in general they were in agreement with
the proposals they did raise some
specific issues with some specific areas
so i'll
cover those as we go down through so if
everybody's got
um
appendix c here if anybody wants to go
into any more detail you know let me
know
what pages appendix see on the um
yeah
those changes yeah okay
so all drivers are required to sign up
to tps update service
um minimum six monthly enhanced bds
checks which is in line with the
statutory standards there's no
objections to that
um it is actually
cheaper for the trade to do that if you
sign up for the updated services 13
pounds a year so that'll be 39 pounds as
opposed to their 48 pounds
every three years and they also have to
um provide certain documentation to do a
dds check and some textiles do struggle
find that sometimes so that will save
them the hassle of doing that it also
gives us the opportunity to check people
if we do have any issues or concerns we
can check people really determine their
license so um i can't see
any objections to that sure
and those dps's are sent to us as well
when they've done when they do them yes
we view them yes yeah what happens is we
get we even get all clear from the dbs
or say it's all clear yes if there's
anything on it then we get a notice from
the dbsender's convictions on it
then we contact the driver and say
you've got convictions you need to bring
them in and we'll assess them in line
with our conviction points
do we want to do that on a three-year
thing because um they're a little bit
like an mot aren't they the dbs service
and you know
yeah there's nobody
so what will happen yeah this will be
six monthly right so what we'll do is uh
we're gonna get a check code basically
so we can go into the dbs they'll give
us a check code we can go into the dbs
system
put in that code and that will tell us
if there's been any changes since their
last tbs
excellent wherever
i'm not sure if you're aware of the dvla
check codes
you can get dvla checker which tells you
if you've got me driving convictions
it's pretty much the same as that
um so yes it's almost instant
um and it should be much easier to to
administer once we get
the challenge is going to be getting
everybody onto that system but we're
mostly not going to make everybody do it
straight from now and we'll phase it in
as their dbs has come up
um
we'll phase it in over over a period of
time um so we'll get everybody on board
um so moving on to the notification
requirements um this is where it's
recommended it should be 48 hours or
some concern raised
whether 48 hours
gave people sufficient time if we for
instance if we were out in the office
bank holidays
we could consider the possibility of two
working days have a weekend or bank
holiday periods i think i'm of the
opinion really
they can
they can notify us by email
whether we're in the office or not
whether we don't pick it up within that
48 hours they can still comply with that
48 hours they can notify us by email or
they can leave a message on our answer
phone
so they can notify us within that 48
hours the fact that we won't pick it up
until the next working day or whatever
they've complied with their their
requirements so i think as the 48 hours
is in the stack from standards
i
i think i'd rather we stick with the 48
hours
because there is scope for them to
report in that time just
thank you
i'm quite happy with 48 hours but i i
just asked the question um over the last
couple of years for example how many
times have you been notified of a
driving offense bulldogging offense
two
driving that the taxi driver is doing
the number of drivers it would it would
be very unlikely that there wouldn't be
one or two more offenses
so there are having raised that there
are one or two that haven't but
obviously we've reminded them of their
responsibilities and we will
yes
information so we've got our revised
convictions policy
which i've got apparently
what's called the nr3 database which is
a database that all local authorities
which are trying to get all the
authorities to use whereas if we refuse
a vehicle license and put it on the nr
free register
and then other authorities can check as
it stands at the moment there's nothing
to stop someone getting refused in
i know manchester um coming down here
and then applying and although we've got
it on our application form have you had
any convictions or refusals or anything
if they
basically lie in that form
we've got no way of checking that
whereas with the nr3 register we would
be able to go on the system and find out
that they have actually been revoked a
license
um
so
that makes sense
um the next
thing is complaints um ways to make
complaints to like since an authority
must be displayed in all licensed
vehicles we have
the committee raises the taxi liaison
committee raised this and
there are obviously they've got quite a
bit of information in the cab already
they're also a bit concerned that
putting complete information would
generate
spurious complaints
um
so we just i think we just need to be
careful how we word the information we
put in there
and we combine it with current
information in the vehicle
um so it's not you know we can't
obviously put a full piece of paper
about complaints in the vehicles
but they've got them they've got the
fair table so we put them in the fair
table
complaints they've got the actual badge
which gives their license number and
everything so we've been combining that
um so what i'll do is i'll work with the
trade and we'll get an
achievable way of doing that in the
easiest possible way
okay um
next is number five safeguarding advice
and guidance this is regarding training
and again we did we discussed that with
the committee initially we were planning
to do some
classroom-based training obviously with
kubernetes and things we weren't able to
do that
um
the the commitment liaison committee did
suggest online training which is uh
which is something we can do
we currently we're providing written
information to all new drivers as we
discussed previously
um so we will i think we'll just again
we'll discuss with the trade look at the
options available
and
and put through an agreeable way of how
we do that training but
the key thing is is we do that training
and i think we improve that we
definitely do that training and it's how
we do that in an achievable way because
online training is not suitable for all
some drivers aren't
computer illiterate shall we say and um
so we may we'd have to do a blended
learning i think some online some
classroom based um
we'll assess that and
you know going forward
number six criminality checks for
vehicle proprietors i don't there's any
debate on that there's unanimously yes
we'll do that
because there are though there's very
few in here torridge there's very few
people
who own a vehicle that aren't a driver
so they get the full check anyway so
it's only going to be one or two that
will need to do a dds check anyway
um next one is in vehicle cctv
all
to identify if there licensing
local circumstances
we've consulted with the police and um
children's services and the drivers
there's nothing
no local circumstances i can see that we
would make it mandatory
they could be owned by owners to make it
mandatory so our plans are to keep it
discretionary
um
but we do need to
obviously monitor the
information coming from the information
commissioner regarding data protections
that's the main issue with cctv is it
completely data protection so what we'll
do is review the requirements and those
that have their
discretionary cctv will make sure it is
up to standard
yeah and sure and that's
displayed in the category yes they've
got a display account so many cats in
cctv have started explaining that they
are they are recording the information
yes
uh the next one number eight criminality
checks for private hire operators that's
the same as the proprietors there are
again we haven't got any operators
that
aren't drivers at the moment we should
be an operator that isn't actually a
driver who hasn't gone through dds
checks they will have to be as checked
so on cctv there's a comment
about um
we're not allowed to video children um
is that a thing that you considered
um devon county
it can be with some school contracts
um
require that they don't record so then
but they can switch it on and so long as
the cctv can be switched on and off
um
then it's compliant
but it depends on the
requirements of the in
school contracts for instance could be
the reason why they may not
want you to record them about parents
and children
i mean would there be cases where you
just take children for instance that
that would be in the school contracts
no other situation then well you talking
about ranks is someone picked up on the
rank a child on the range
yeah see that wouldn't be it's only
it's not
prohibited by law it's prohibited by
devon county as part of their school
contract
so if they operate on the rank they're
not prohibited by law
obviously they've got a lot of cash for
everything to clearly display the uh
people that they are recording there's
nothing in law to prevent the taxi
driver from doing it
sure
so if you're getting attached to him all
the time has potential
and you see that there's a cctv camera
he called him
can you ask the driver not to do that
can you say i don't want it i don't give
permission yeah
yeah i'll have to check that out
actually
i think that's a no
you can force them to see yeah i don't
think you can yeah no ask them to turn
it off
because you're giving
you're gaining entry to the cabin to
give you your permission basically right
to for them to operate as they need to
um and they have a right to refuse you
if you don't operate comply with their
conditions as well so i i think it's a
no but um
i wouldn't double check just to check
the legalities of it but um so what
happens to cctv footage so
it's sort of eliminated
yeah it's usually stored i think it's 28
days
yeah
[Music]
slightly difficult to see the comments
in association with the uh decisions
so yeah there are a lot of comments
let's keep going yes yeah
and so eight criminality checks for
operators we've covered um
booking and dispatch staff
again there's no objections to that
that's basically
those people on the end of the phone
aren't drivers
would also be dds check by their
employer which has been the taxi
operator not by us but they need to
provide us with evidence if they've done
it
um record keeping is there's a few
amendments to the record which is
minimal
um number 11
drives and
again just informing
obtaining the percent of the book
point system number 12 we are in place
already
there's no particular issues there
and review of licenses already issued
which we would do
if there's any changes to policy we then
look back at existing drivers as well as
new drivers
so next is the vehicle admissions policy
um
the committee discussed this with the
committee um
2026 is obviously a goal to move to
the committee did express concerns at
the moment regarding the availability of
satisfactory vehicles and the cost
implications of buying in vehicles
and the favorite charging points current
charge times
um
so what i would propose is we review in
12 months maybe
um to establish obviously as it starts
at the moment there is there isn't the
infrastructure in taurus to be able to
do anything
um
and it's
at the moment um
i don't think we're in a position to be
forced upon
[Music]
people now but if we review in 12 months
to see what the position is
we could then review that 2026 at the
moment we'll
stick with the 2026.
if suddenly we get lots of grants
available and things to encourage
electric vehicles we may bring back
going forward so that we can have
regular reviews so we don't get lost
with that one um can support me today
i think it would be a good idea if we um
started to plan as soon as possible a
charging point or charging points
actually on the taxi range so that if
you know if taxis
electric vehicles are
they are rapidly becoming far more
widespread in fact
my my two brothers
each brought different electric vehicles
which totally surprised me almost
um you know so they are getting far more
commonplace yeah and i can see
some of the schemes available that you
know we are going to have electric taxis
so yeah it's inevitable
exactly i can see that possibly by next
year someone right we'll have a electric
taxi here so we're gonna we you know
we're really bound to have charging
points on the right so that they're
reserved for any electric vehicle or
whatever so i think you know it's not
gonna be waiting for another yeah wait
until
before we start thinking by doing that
if you put the charging point in
you're encouraging you wouldn't go down
that way it's going to take a bit of
thought as well from health and safety
angle wouldn't it particularly trip
hazards there's going to be leads in
place where people are sort of like
moving to vehicles and then sort that
aspect would move you could be
unplugging and plug in and how many
plugs because there's different charging
yeah yeah points etc etc but yeah yeah
so yeah councillor hayes might know more
here
because i think devon county wants to do
a transport plan
um with elections obviously
transport links into taxis and buses and
things so whether there is any plan on
the
devon county
we need to get funding for county-wide
ed points
i mean i think you should go to climate
committee for
further consideration and this discount
of 20 percent is that that was
something which
we've approved
we put forward um
some of the taxi data committees
um
that was not much of an incentive for 20
um
so whether we want to
consider that um
obviously
the licensing team is self-funded
so we can afford to give away licenses
for free basically
but
it could be if we get funding if there
is further down the line we get funding
whether some of that funding could be
used to subsidize it
okay so again when we review that
as
as infrastructure
progresses we can review that again
there is an electric taxi company which
i think operates advanced school or
stickers um
yeah there were problems with the
stickers we've got and damaging
paintwork so
we'll look to again in consultation
because we do have to have the advanced
booking stickers per single common
guidance
but we can change how we do that so
we'll have a review of that and consult
with the actual operators themselves as
the best way of achieving that
and finally was the drivers badges to be
displayed on the dashboard around the
lanyard so i think that's uh
no problems with that
so just a couple of things before we
finished out
as i said we
went to the taxi laser committee a
couple of other things they raised um
was around the taxi feeder rank which
we've discussed and a shelter at the
rank also they did ask to pass on
thanks to the grants team and north
devon plus for the provision and
administering of the grants during the
programming period to the minute
that the taxi trade wish to
um give their appreciation to the
support provided by the by the council
during the period
thank you um
i think the um
the installation of a taxi shelter
similar to a bus shelter is it it is
important you know we've got bus
shelters all along the kitchen but
there's absolutely nothing i did raise
this a couple of years ago probably
a little bit longer
but clearly nothing's happened since
then but you know it is something we no
point just letting it
roll on year after year we actually need
to you know start the process of
whether it's having headache counselor
whether it's torridge that are gonna
provide it i'm not sure but there must
be a way of funding a simple shelter
they're not that expensive and there's
plenty of room to put one at least one
shelter the town clerk of biddeford town
council costed it at about eight to ten
thousand pounds and it's something that
billy for town council could provide but
we were talking about this just before
we thought maybe so like you know using
some of this 11 and up fund or
you know various other means to sort of
like subsidize it by it whatever right
rather than still be talking about it in
12 months time yeah i think which we
seem to do on this committee quite a lot
we talked about the ssgp though
welcome back
that's it right so
the proposal is to accept these
recommendations on block um i'll move
that from the chair unless anybody's got
any objections counselor second in all
in favor
unanimous
thank you very much
ah come
on all right next item
gambling act statements of principles
item seven
yes in accordance um the gambling act we
need to prepare a statement principles
which is a policy in effect and that
needs to be reviewed every three years
it's now due for a
review so this is really just to get the
committee's approval
um to put that forward for consultation
there are very few amendments to there's
um there hasn't been much change there's
currently of the gambling commission are
currently doing a review so
as once that's completed we may need to
review again but as it stands at the
moment there's only minor changes to
update
from the policy
and provide a bit more guidance to
applicants um
but it's just to ask the committee for
approval to uh
yeah implications climate change will
seem to implement measures to reduce
effects of climate change it's just
interesting how that relates to gambling
provisions
don't drive to the peninsula
yeah it's just
any type of things that come forward
just to make sure
[Music]
yeah so it's been proposed by councillor
bushby and seconded by councillor clark
and that we put this challenge for
consultation all in favor
consideration ford
plan yes sure
yep
if we can put obviously the taxi policy
on the next um agenda
um yeah and also the gambling policy
will come back with the next
that'd be the december one
in january we need to review our boat
licensing policy that's up through
that on the january
committee that's all i've got at the
moment
um presumably we
license
um
affairs and circuses at victoria
no we don't
so
the only the only thing we'd like from
it is alcohol or regulated entertainment
which is food but for turks services we
don't
like services
we give yeah they apply
[Music]
startled by the amount of plastic stuff
being sold drinks plastic containers
with actual batteries in them operating
lights and
i think i mean sweater we could
influence what they do because we're
talking about
green licensing with the estates people
with our properties
it's wonder whether we have the
influence on
respect for services and affairs and
other things
obviously
the other thing is there's a planning
application for dog walking area in
northern um
because that presumably doesn't become
subject to a license
no it's only an actual boarding panel
thank
you yeah clash of hands actually raises
an interesting point because
town council whenever we
we recently had a little uh
fare about um 2024
we had to apply for a license
everything we do have to apply for a
license so the word license would apply
almost that is the licensing company
that are issuing that but clearly that's
not the case that's the case so why do
they call it a license why can't they
just call it an agreement or something
else other than a license it seems a bit
of a
ridiculous thing you've got a licensed
licensing committee
but licenses are being issued for a
variety of events far more than what we
ever discussed
because the licensing committee only
covers the statutory functions
um of the gambling act license taxis
um so certain areas that don't fall
under
the legislation to require a licensing
committee
and we don't issue those licenses
so
yeah
so you can't see any scope within our
this committee for influencing
activities we control through licensing
um in terms of
you know more green activities
that was important
because
the council issued licenses for
things on their
yeah land is that what you're doing yes
well we issue a consent so if we should
consent we can put um stipulations in
place for example you mentioned the
surface um when
the surface came in a couple of years
ago they did a tremendous amount of
damage to the
actual surface of grass so this time
when the application came in from the
surface to actually use the victoria
power we said you can but we're mindful
of the damage you do so they had to put
a bond i think it was about two or three
thousand pounds
which could be used to do any repairs so
you know it was there there are ways
that you can but conditions on that
whether it's worth raising something
through the climate
yeah
because that would be yeah
because that's a council
decision
um and we were talking about a green
checklist for seminars and conferences
[Music]
as part of the license or the
application
yeah to apply for a license on council
land you could
there's been movement on sort of uh
polystyrene and plastic items at the
seaside and stuff and it's the same sort
of thing really
so in terms of the use of plastics
during any event
that the right
department to be talking with would be
property because when an application for
an event license is made it goes through
property
so it sounds like already you've
probably got that that line of um
discussion already going so that would
be a good a good
way to cover that and in terms of using
the term license unfortunately it's a
legal term
so we have to use but we do tend to use
the terminology of an event license for
a circus
so a license is a temporary
use of land as opposed to a lease or any
other agreement
so the difficulty is that we have to
keep calling the license because that's
what the legislation states
unfortunately
again it's something to bear in mind we
are reviewing the whole license process
so that's something that you can bear in
mind going forward thank you for that go
to the consultation review then
um
as far as i know it's with property and
it's very early stages at the moment as
a result of the new mistakes manager
officer coming in yeah
thank you
thank you very much there's no part to
it so there's no further
to discuss so
the next meeting is was at the eighth
december
first first december what time
ten o'clock ten o'clock